[Applaudissements]
cali oqali j'aime fort merci mon cap
une landaise gilles verdez à vous avez
énormément de points forts voulait
commencer par ça franchement vous est
brillant vous êtes drôle vous êtes
intelligent et ce que j'aime par dessus
tout chez vous c'est que vous ne
renoncez jamais même dans l'adversité
vous vous battez toujours vous êtes un
gagnant si vous étiez napoléon on
n'aurait jamais perdu à waterloo road
mais vous avez un point fort qui pour
moi dépasse tout c'est que vous sentez
et là je parle
personnellement plus que
professionnellement vous sentez quand on
va mal vous n'appelez jamais sauf le
week-end et à chaque fois ça tombe quand
vous sentez cas quelque chose qui va pas
et vous remonter le moral et c'est pas
quand ça va bien qu'on voit ses amis
c'est quand on est dans la difficulté
que rencontrent ses vrais amis et pour
ça je vous remercie parce que je ne
l'oublierai jamais ça c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
ça s'appelle jamais mais cette année
cyril vous avez trop de points faibles
le principal